مفهوم الأساسية مرتبط في جوهره بـ
مفهوم القياس في ميكانيكا الكم
قبل ما اتطوّرت ميكانيكا النقطة
كان العلماء عارفين عموماً
إنه لو عندك نظام في حالة معيّنة
وكانت في حالة محددة
وأجريت قياساً عليه هتحصل على
نتيجة واضحة ومحددة
في ميكانيكا الكم الأمر مختلف، ممكن يكون عندك
نظام في حالة محددة تماماً
وبس لما تجري قياسات معيّنة
عليه ممكن تطلع نتائج عشوائية
عشان أوضّح الفكرة دي أكتر، لازم
أجيب مفهوم التراكب
التراكب مش مفهوم غريب أو جديد
هو مبني على نظام بيعرض
تركيبة خطية من حالات متعددة
في نفس الوقت، وتقدر تتخيّله
مثلاً كموجة راديو بتحمل
ترددات مختلفة كتير، ومفيش
أي شرط إنساني بيمنع ده
اللي بيدّي التراكب نكهته الكمومية هو حقيقة
قياس النظام
هاشرحه بمثال
تخيّل عندك نظام من السهام
وجهّزت النظام
بحيث كل السهام بتشاور لليسار
وبعدين رحت و
سألت النظام: إنت لأعلى ولا لأسفل؟
وسألت كل سهم، لأن السهم اللي بيشاور لليسار ممكن يتعبّر عنه
أو يتوصف
كتراكب بين
لأعلى ولأسفل، هتلاقي
النتائج خمسين بالمية لأعلى
وخمسين بالمية لما تسأل: إنت لأعلى؟
هتاخد النتيجة دي من النظام
وبعدين تقدر تجهّز
حالة مختلفة للنظام، بحيث نص السهام
بتشاور لأعلى والنص التاني
بتشاور لأسفل وسألت نفس السؤال
وهتاخد نفس النتيجة
النظامين مختلفين جداً
وانت اتخلّصت من المعلومة دي
لمدة طويلة دلوقتي
إزاي تعرف الفرق؟ الحالتين
مختلفتين جداً
لأن في الحالة الأولى جهّزت النظام في
حالة نقية، وفي أسئلة معيّنة تقدر
تسألها للنظام وهيدّيك إجابة حتمية
مش عشوائية، والسؤال ده هو: إنت يسار ولا يمين؟
هيقولك مية بالمية يسار
في الحالة التانية مفيش سؤال تقدر
تسأله يدّيك مية بالمية لأنه خليط
نتيجة حتمية لأنه خليط
يعني لو سألت يسار ولا يمين
هتطلع عشوائية لأن نصهم لأعلى
والنص لأسفل، لو سألت لأعلى ولا لأسفل
نفس الموضوع، هتكون خمسين بالمية
إيه علاقة ده بالعشوائية الكمومية؟
ممكن تتخيّل الأمر
زي رمية عملة، هتطلع صورة أو كتابة
بس مش زي رمية عملة عادية خالص
لأن لما بترمي عملة
السبب الوحيد إنك مش عارف النتيجة
هو إنك مش عارف
الطاقة اللي رميت بيها العملة والزاوية واللحظة
والظروف المحيطة في الأوضة
وهكذا، يعني لو كنت عارف كل
المتغيرات دي كنت تقدر تتنبّأ بالنتيجة
دي متغيرات خفية على المراقب
ولسنين طويلة العلماء فكّروا إن فيه
متغيرات مشابهة في ميكانيكا الكم بتظهر
على شكل عشوائية
وماكانش إلا حتى
الأعمال الرائدة لـ John Bell في الستينات اللي أثبتت فعلاً
إن الأمر مش كده
ودلوقتي كل فيزيائي
بيعترف إنه مفيش
نظرية متغيرات خفية متوافقة مع ميكانيكا الكم
يعني صح فعلاً إنك لما بتقيس نظام
الطبيعة بتكشف عن النتيجة
ومهما فكّرت في الموضوع
هيفضل يبهرني